they say actions speak louder than words
but the words heard in this Glasgow
boardroom today have been reverberating
across the country and across the border
it's a right thing to do for me as Chief
Constable to clearly state that
institutional racism sexism misogyny and
discrimination exist
police Scotland is institutionally
racist and discriminatory City in
Livingston going further than any of his
policing peers in calling out the
culture within his own Force what I've
said today because of the unique role
and the unique powers of the police
service we need to be at the Forefront
of recognizing these institutional
barriers calling them out and thereafter
more importantly making sure we then
take action to make please singer as
good as it can be shaku bio was killed
in police custody in 2015 after he was
restrained by officers a public inquiry
is looking into whether his race was a
factor in his treatment none of the
offices involved were prosecuted his
family has welcomed the chief
Constable's remarks today but they want
to see action it's a significant
Milestone it's never happened before in
the United Kingdom but in the end these
are all words what will count is what
happens at the end of sheikhubayo's
struggle the family struggle in terms of
the inquiry if real change is brought
about and those who are responsible are
held accountable
so Ian said individual officers and
staff are absolutely not racist and
sexist
but his words put pressure on other
police leaders to call out systemic
discrimination including the
Metropolitan Police Commissioner
and they've already resonated at the
very top of government in Scotland
I remember raising issues around racism
in the police force South crowd police
as it was back then when I was stopped
and searched over a dozen times as a
young boy whether it was in my car or
walking with my friends in the street or
in airports at the time and saw the
acknowledgment from the chief Constable
is very welcome indeed so Ian is due to
retire this year his bold statement will
have to be recognized by his successor
for there to be significant change and
realistically real reform would take
years but self-reflection is an
important start Becky Cottrell Sky News
Glasgow